robert shiller argues that while Wall
Street financial firms should be
criticized for their role in the 2008
collapse it's now necessary to figure
out a way to harness the power of the
financial sector to advance the public
good this book TV event is just over an
hour
good evening and welcome to tonight's
meeting of the commonwealth club of san
fer of california the place where you're
in the know find us on the internet at
commonwealth club org i'm corey johnson
bloomberg west editor-at-large and
moderator for today's program it's my
pleasure to introduce today's special
guest Robert Shiller Robert Shiller is a
Yale economist he's won a slew of
economist awards widely quoted widely
admired one of Bloomberg's 50 most
important people in finance yada yada
but there's an important reason we
listened to Robert Shiller he's an
amazing ability to see problems coming
down the road and if you listen to
Robert Shiller you could have avoided a
lot of those problems maybe you could a
little made a little money in the
process what kind of problem how about
the problematic belief that the market
is efficient that everything bad and
good is already priced into the market
or the price of any given stock Shiller
pierced that whole idea back in the
early 80s before most of us at her nurse
heard about it or seen what Warren
Buffett could do to squeeze value out of
the supposedly efficient markets in the
late eighties he proved through
behavioral finance that the market was
likely be much more volatile and
emotional than any rational calculation
might suggest in some ways predicting
the crash of 1987 not done in the late
80s and late 90s explained why the
dot-com bubble had to pop predicting the
march two thousand market crash in his
best-selling book irrational exuberance
and for all that Schiller is probably
best known for calling the overinflated
housing market in 2003 he wrote a
Brookings paper titled is there a bubble
in the housing market he was widely
mocked for a prediction that housing
prices could fall by maybe fifty percent
but in just about five years they fell
forty percent a dramatic dramatic fall
so what's happened in the housing market
what's happened in the stock market the
idea of the kind of risks that are out
there and can be seen with a careful eye
Robert Shiller student proven that but
his new book is a really interesting
take on the potential for finance and
the potential for what our society can
look like at a time when there's so much
right about who should be taxed about
what the one percent is about who
deserves what they have and how
capitalism even works so Robert Shiller
we're glad to have you join us here with
the Commonwealth Club California well
Cory you gave a number of examples of me
predicting disasters have one sort or
another so I'm liking to get out of that
mode I I'm not trying to predict any
disasters tonight I think what I want to
do is talk from a longer time frame
about how we got here and where we're
going I tell my students we have a
hundred year horizon because you're
going to young people are going to live
a hundred years maybe or their children
will a lot of changes are coming and
it's hard to write about them and think
about them but that the title of my book
finance and the good society was meant I
don't know how you hear that but it was
meant to have a little tension in it
because it seems like an oxymoron
finance seems to be this evil business
that makes the rich richer and it seems
to be opposed to the good society the
I've been teaching finance at Yale
University for 25 years now and I also
teach to the whole world because my my
Yale course is on open Yale and
broadcast you can take my course by the
way it's online and it's free I have
exams and problems that's if you really
want to go the whole way but I won't
grade you so
but I've been concerned over the years
that it almost seems like I'm doing a
bad thing so I feel because people are
so angry about finance today and it's it
seems evil I feel a little bit like an
ROTC instructor during the Vietnam War
Catherine rampell wrote an article in
The New York Times a couple months ago
based on her asking top universities
what fraction of your students went into
financial services and the general
answer she got was for just before this
crisis was something like twenty five
percent she was questioning whether that
was too high the record was Princeton
which had forty six percent going into
finance in 2006 that's some people that
you're frowning I think I I'm touching a
nerve here i guess that people are they
think whatever happened to science or
engineering or education or the helping
professions is something wrong well I'm
not going to say what the percent should
be but I want to think about that and I
think that see part of the reason no i
don't i hope i don't anger some of you
i've given talks like this in the past
and it sounds like I'm apologizing so
let me say right up front that there are
some really awful people in finance okay
and so but there are also the difference
is there are some really awful people in
education too but you don't read about
them in newspapers right because they
don't get rich doing they get lazy for
example that's not a good newspaper
story
but the thing is that there's a
fundamental problem with being so angry
at finance and that is that we're going
through a worldwide miracle of economic
growth in all of the emerging areas of
the world in in Asia in the Middle East
in Latin America in the former Soviet
countries even in sub-saharan Africa and
I believe this is because of our
financial capitals we're emerging into
an era of financial capitalism and
financial capitalism is what is it it's
really about new methods of allocating
resources incentivizing people and
managing risks and it makes business
work now I'm sounding awfully I don't
have a fro market but I'm I'm going to
come back and say that it only works
when you have proper regulation the
system we have is an invention that was
developed through experience over
hundreds of years and the countries that
have adopted it have done really well
and now it's kind of an open secret that
this works so when Lula became president
of Brazil he didn't see the people
thought he was leftist and he was not
going to be friendly to business but he
was friendly to business and now there's
a miracle in Brazil but it's not just
Brazil it's all over the the financial
crisis has created a sense of serious
problem with this but I don't think that
it's tipping the balance so that we
would actually stop this progress not
not at the current point but there's a
sense that you'll get in some
discussions of the recent crisis that
it's it's some malefactors who caused
the crisis whether our malefactors but
it seems to me that the question should
be what kind of economic system do we
want you know we live in a world where
there's all kinds of people and there
are some people that scare others
they're there they haven't committed any
crimes yet right and you kind of want to
stay away from them but they're out
there and unless they commit a crime
they're going to be out there so we have
to design a system is that is as nice
that makes it encourages them to be
constructive there are aggressive
selfish greedy people okay they tend
sometimes to go into finance because
it's a good place if that's your
personality although I tell my students
if you are if you know you might know
that if you are sociopathically finance
because there are rules and regulations
and you will be discovered that's my
thing and so try to go into something
that's more more benign my advice so the
the the problem that created this crisis
was a couple of things that we didn't
understand and I think we understand
better now one of them was the systemic
vulnerability of the whole system we
didn't have data on the
interconnectedness of financial
institutions the dodd-frank act is going
to provide more data but we didn't have
it and we didn't understand how
vulnerable the system was we got very
leveraged there was a lot of borrowing
inflating asset prices and not not well
enough understood the other thing is
that we had a tremendous bubble in real
estate markets and that bubble was not
appreciated that there was a you know
that one thing about people I had talked
about human psychology one of the most
striking thing about people is that they
can be brilliant in some dimensions and
really ignorant than others if you think
about history you realize that somehow
it became conventional wisdom that home
prices never fall and I just find that
amazing I actually talked to people
before this move and try to understand
their thinking
there are very smart people and you know
they would be kind of dismissive of my
asking and if I pressured them they'd
say well home prices have never fallen
and i said well wait about what about
Japan right now or what about the Great
Depression and they would say well
that's Japan and that the Great
Depression that was a long time ago and
that's all they had to say but somehow
we got into this crisis because of those
mistakes so we have to fix them but what
do we do to fix them that that's the
question that that's what I think is a
challenge for young people today we want
but the question is what should a young
person who is idealistic do should he or
she avoid finance I don't think so
because I think that it's so much the
hope of our future and it involves so
much transformation you don't want to
leave it to the sociopaths you don't
want to you don't want to there's a
moral responsibility to get involved
with things that matter we understand a
lot more fundamental about finance
through our development of behavioral
finance that's the science of finance
with study of psychology and sociology
and other social sciences embedded also
we have something called neuro economics
now that's just developing so many
different intellectual traditions are
getting involved the medical school is
getting involved in economics now
because they're learning so much about
the brain and one thing we learned is
that people have a lot of circuits in
their brain that that bring out certain
behaviors on
that make it you have an impulse to be
selfish and if there's a sale and the
items are being grabbed up quickly you
have an impulse to run in there and grab
before the next guy but at the same time
you have an altruistic spirit and that's
well established now it's part of your
repertory and the thing that's nice
about modern society is that we've found
ways to mitigate the bad tendencies and
put them in in in good stead but it
doesn't we can never get people to be
perfect they'll always be egoistic and
selfish and all those things at
sometimes and that's just the life so my
history of financial institutions is a
history of learning about these things
so for example in 1811 New York the
state of New York created a new
securities law which did two things
first I me a corporate law it's allowed
anybody to set up a corporation with
minimal restrictions you used to get
have to go to the legislature and get
special permission and and secondly they
they created limited liability for
investors and what that meant is if you
invest it in a company and the company
was later accused of wrongdoing the the
complaint the lawsuit could never go
after your assets because you invested
in the company before that people were
afraid to invest in companies they
didn't really know so it made everything
like a family business you had to have
people you trust the law changed
everything and it was in it was copied
over all the world now according to
David Moss who studied these carefully
what I think it did is it created a
sense of pleasure in investing it made
people used to invest in lotteries
they'd love to gamble that's another
human trait I love the excitement of
finding out whether your number came up
by creating limited liability it became
fun the same way a lottery is fun I mean
this people have to enjoy life right
there has to be something
that makes you get out of bed in the
morning and gives you some excitement it
so we design things that give you that
feeling that securities law has been the
source of a lot of our innovation
because now investors it looks like
they're playing a game it looks a little
selfish but it drives our economy other
people karl marx looked at it and said
it's gambling and he thought we should
shut it down worse than that worse than
that but the after years of
experimenting with that people think
well maybe we have to let people indulge
in in these feelings so so okay so it
let me move i have another maybe i'll go
for another 10-15 minutes i wanted to
talk about the future and about some of
the ideas that i talked about i'm going
to start from tomorrow and and then move
a little bit more and more into the wild
future what happens tomorrow is
president obama has said that he will
sign the JOBS Act that that name for the
act was a little bit the misleading
maybe for some political reasons it's
not about jobs it's called jumpstart our
business startups that spells jobs and
what it is its controversial I like it
though notably as an experiment it may
or may not work well but let me tell you
what is the most interesting part of the
JOBS Act the JOBS Act was was created in
response to requests from internet
website providers who wanted to create a
crowdfunding website for entrepreneurs
entrepreneurs to you if you're trying to
start a business you can put it up on
their website and say I'm looking for
money and then thousands of investors or
millions all over the world can send
money and you can start a business now
this is a wild sounding idea isn't that
but it's endorsed by a lot of internet
people I think it's just about as wild
as
wikipedia sounded at the beginning so if
I came to you tenant when did wicked say
before Wikipedia started and said I'm
going to open an online encyclopedia and
I'm going to let anybody in the world
add to it my first reaction would have
been that's a dumb idea right it's not
going to be a good encyclopedia but it's
just we learned something about how
people can work together through
Wikipedia so I think this is a good
experiment now what Congress has done is
they're worried that it's going to be
there's a lot of cheats out there
unfortunately and someone is going to
steal money from someone else this way
so one thing they've done in the
legislation is that for people you have
to document your income to the website
and for people with incomes up to forty
thousand dollars you can't invest more
than 2% of your income which is what
eight hundred dollars so it's small for
each individual and that protects people
right it can't go that bad and i think
the maximum is 10 thousand dollars that
you can put in eat if you have a higher
income so it's designed to protect
people but you know even if people can
only invest eight hundred dollars if you
get enough of them you've got real
capital and what the thing that's
exciting to me about it it reminds me of
an insight that Friedrich Hayek had in
the 1940s in his book a road to serfdom
and that is that when you really think
about it information about the economy
is very widely dispersed across people
he said that there's a lamentable fact
in now in 1944 that people think that
scientists know everything our scholars
know everything but in fact so many of
the important things that you need to
know about business are dispersed their
local things like where would be a good
place to open another coffee houser what
kind of coffee house would sell in our
district and that kind of dispersing
could benefit from crowdfunding the way
wikipedia did I don't know if it's going
to work but i'll start with let me move
on because i have so many ideas here and
I can't get through them all that's
tomorrow Obama said he'll sign it
tomorrow
but you won't see by the way these
websites for a while because they have
to go through regulatory hoops and but
maybe in a year you'll be starting a
business through some of you in
crowdfunding next thing the benefit
corporation now this is actually two
years old in the first benefit
corporation was created in Maryland in
2010 and what it is and now eight states
have them but it's spreading and I
assume most states will have them
eventually the what is a benefit
corporation it is a corporation which in
its original charter defines some public
benefit it's a for-profit corporation
but it has a dual mandate make profits
and do something for society or for the
environment some cause good cause and
the company can write into its charter
its own definition of what social
benefit it wants to pursue so if that
means it can attract investors who focus
on that particular thing I noticed that
there's a fertilizer company makes
fertilizer and its charter it says that
it wants to restore a healthy nitrogen
potassium sodium balance in in the earth
soil all right now that's not a cause
that most of you here are sympathetic to
but I think that's the kind of that's
where we have a democratized finite
where people who are interested in that
cause can invest in something like that
we can have a lot of diversity and
benefit corporations and they'll appeal
to people now the question is will it
succeed as a for-profit now the American
idea has been companies have to be
exclusively for profit if you blur that
they're going to play tricks there's all
kinds of bad things will happen well the
benefit corporation is another
experiment maybe it won't work maybe we
have to tinker with it but my guess is
that it will turn out to be more
profitable than a strictly for-profit
corporation now that may sound
paradoxical how could that be if you
tell the board of director
is just make profits don't do anything
else or if you tell the board we want
you to make profits but we want you to
be contributing to the community as well
I think the latter will make more
profits in the long run because they
will have the loyalty of the community
the support of the community they will
have the workers who feel better about
the company because they feel that this
isn't just about making money so that's
my prediction that this will be another
success there hasn't been a benefit
corporation in any country yet this is
i'm giving you two examples of american
innovation that's just happening now I
want to move more into the future I'm
thinking about making philanthropy a
more rewarding experience I tell my
students my students think there'll be
billionaires and then maybe some of them
will you never know in the next 50 years
right we're growing so fast but I I
think that they should give it away it
doesn't make any sense to accumulate
money Andrew Carnegie said that in his
gospel of wealth in eighteen seventy
nine I think it's still true that
there's a moral imperative to give away
your well it's kind of a game life is a
game in some sense I don't mean to make
that cynical your statement but you
you're you're trying to do something
that stimulates you and it wakes you up
and making a lot of money is fine if
you're going to give it all away right
or most of it away and so but the
problem is that it doesn't seem very
satisfying or enjoy there's something
missing about philanthropy when someone
calls you up at dinnertime and and they
try to get you to give money and you
wouldn't want to give away your life's
work just like that and then it's gone
it doesn't it doesn't seem exciting so
incidentally I think probably all of you
here have logged on to Wikipedia at some
point right and have you noticed that
there are these banners at the top
saying please donate Jimmy Wales is
asking you please donate a hundred
dollars to Wikipedia if you and I won't
ask for a show of hands but I've asked
it in other
it's like ten percent has done it why
not why didn't you give a hundred
dollars well I think that we there's
something yeah you maybe you would
thought you'd do it eventually but you
haven't done it yet it's not something
that you rush out and do so I I thought
we have to think of new institutions
that are more fun and more rewarding if
you've made a billion dollars and then
you just give it away it just seems so
anti climactic maybe so my idea i'm
trying to think of how to do this but
it's just an idea and it may not be
exactly right i want to define a new
kind of nonprofit this is not a benefit
corporation this is a non-profit which i
call a participation nonprofit and what
it is it has to be created by the
government but the institution has the
structure has to be created by the
government what it is it's you can make
eight i antigen this for something like
a hospital a nonprofit hospital or a
school or a college you can make a
donation to these and it's
tax-deductible just like a charity well
it is a charity it's a non-profit it's
for the public good but there's a
difference your donation takes the form
of your buying shares in the nonprofit
and then the company the nonprofit pays
dividends from its income to your
account and it's yours to allocate with
the one proviso only to charity only the
good you can't spend it on yourself now
i don't know if this this is again I
know if I'm connecting with you on this
but it seems more fun to me because we
have a natural desire to accumulate and
we want to be appreciate where
egotistical everyone wants to be loved
and to be praised and so how about
letting you accumulate money in a
special account as a result of your
having made a gift wouldn't that be more
interesting and more exciting it also
you want to put the money into something
into some enterprise that's going to be
big and important like Wikipedia for
example or something like that I think
they could get a lot more money
with a framework like that and then you
could pull it out you know you don't but
what happens to nonprofits today they
set them up a hundred years ago like a
hospital it's not a great Hospital maybe
you know people aren't that happy but it
does make a profit and it keeps plowing
it back into the hospital and you know
smart people know that you know it
should go elsewhere well this would give
you some kind of oversight I'm thinking
anyway let me move on to some other
ideas continuous work out mortgage I
think that we should have mortgages that
designed with a pre-planned work out if
the economy turns sour and home prices
fall or unemployment rises what does it
work out today if you can't pay your
mortgage you go back to the mortgage
servicer and you say give me a workout
and they will say no and that's the end
of it they may keep you in doubt for a
long time what I want it to be
pre-planned and automatic and continuous
and that means that as home prices fall
your payment's keep going down as long
as it keeps falling they keep going down
and you don't have to ask anything
they'll just do it autumn it'll all be
computerized now that sounds a little
strange it's never been done but why not
we could do that now I think they'd have
to charge a higher rate this is a free
market institution we need the
government only to regulate these and
make sure they're clean and clarify the
legitimacy of them but I think if we had
had continuous work out mortgages we
wouldn't have the problem we're in now
we wouldn't have more than 10 million
households underwater we wouldn't have
all this complaints that you bailed out
the corporations and now you're not
bailing out me the homeowner because we
wouldn't have had the but you would have
been automatically bailed out not by the
government but by a private institution
and we wouldn't have maybe had to bail
out the the institutions either now you
might be asking how is this going to
work how can a mortgage originator
originate a mortgage that has these big
reductions in payments in bad times well
therefore I think we need more financial
sophistication to make that happen and
finance is a beautiful theory that tells
you how lots of things can have
and if you think about it one thing is
they could securitize these mortgages
the original this sounds like a bad word
right people hate the securitized
mortgages but it spreads risks that was
always right and if it's done honestly
and well it will do that so that the
mortgage originator puts it in
portfolios all over the world and it
doesn't hit them so hard also we could
develop futures and options markets on
real estate prices well I have to say I
have been involved in doing just that I
have the S&P case-shiller home price
indices at my colleague carl case and i
originally developed and we have the
Chicago Mercantile Exchange started
offering futures prices on 10 US cities
futures markets for home prices
including San Francisco and they've been
going for five years now so you can
hedge or the retailer creating products
like continuous work out mortgages can
hedge the risk the CMA just opened a few
days ago a new options market based on
our indices so the problem is they're
not working well yet there's not many
people into it we have to figure things
out but I think in the future we'll have
this is the opposite of what warren
buffett said I respect the man a lot but
he's not always right and he said
derivatives are weapons of mass
destruction well I think they they're
dangerous just like anything that's
powerful is dangerous but we can
regulate them we can get it right and it
will make for a better world maybe
that's all he meant that's like nuclear
power I won't get into that but so
another idea I have a couple more
minutes maybe another idea is that the
government should issue debt indexed but
they ain't they issued debt as you know
right if we have a huge national debt
which is it concern now the US
government has never in its history
issued equity which means shares why not
companies do it they issues both debt
and equity and options and warrants and
all kinds of things but unswept the
other thing let's at least move a little
bit beyond the most conservative form of
obligation from the government so the
proposal that mark Kempster
I have made he's a professor at York
University in Toronto we propose that
the government issue what we call trills
a trill is a one trillionth share of
u.s. gdp okay we just sell shares in our
country now the advantage to doing this
is that if we have a recession the
obligation of the government goes down
automatically with the GDP I'm also
saying we should leverage them up to it
I won't try that here if Greece had
issued trills Greece especially if they
were leveraged there wouldn't be a Greek
crisis because the the declining gdp in
Greece would have bailed them out
automatically why are we doing all these
after the fact bailouts the government
you know Angela Merkel has to deal with
the German conservatism well I know why
they're conservative you go in after the
fact and just say well they're they're
messed up so that we have to give them
our money it doesn't feel right or or
bailing out companies it should all be
pre-planned it should be according to
rules so that's what I have in mind i'm
going to have one more idea and then
i'll stop for questions this has to do
with the Occupy Wall Street complaint
the 99 well they say we are the
ninety-nine percent this refers to the
fact that the top 1% of earners in the
United States saw an increase since 1990
of their real after-tax earnings of
almost sixty percent whereas the bottom
ninety-nine percent have seen a decline
so something is going wrong with our
income distribution and I don't see
plans to deal with it so I have a plan
which is very simple I think that I call
it inequality indexation of the tax
system or sometimes I call it inequality
insurance cuz it's a financial concept
we have a progressive tax system we
should agree now that if some threshold
of inequality is reached we will
automatically raise taxes it won't
Congress decides today
that when the ninety-nine percent is
sufficiently disadvantage relative to
the one percent we stop it because we
put increased taxes on the top 1% and
it's automatic we decide now if whenever
that happens it goes on automatically
instructions to the IRS change the rates
to make it happen if I don't know what
the there's an article by ian ayres and
aaron Edlin and in the New York Times
that described it in this simple term so
I'm oversimplifying a bit but as they
did but the idea is how much worse do
you think we should let inequality get
in this country how about fifty percent
worse or seventy percent worse isn't
there some limit to where we will let it
go and if there is why can't we agree
now to have a contingency plan that will
automatically stop at them I think that
we're much more likely to succeed in
dealing with inequality if we plan for
it in advance that's what finance is all
about it's like insurance if you worried
about your house burning down you have
to buy insurance on it before it burns
down if after its ashes you go to the
insurance agent and say I'd like
insurance on this they won't give it to
you anymore and it's the same thing if
we let inequality get really bad as I'm
not saying it will I don't know but it's
been trending worse and it could get
right no one can no one can gainsay that
if we just let that happen and it does
happen when that day comes it's going to
be hard to raise taxes on the rich it's
easier to do it now and but that's
finance and that's the democratizing
finance so I'll stop with that and I'll
turn it over it we've got a ton of great
questions from the audience so please
feel free to send up more questions you
are listening to remind you to listening
the Commonwealth Club of California
radio program and our guest the
influential yell economist and
best-selling author Robert Shiller
talking about his new book finance in
the good society and it is a
thought-provoking read someone has a
couple questions that take some of the
questions I've gotten the cards here I
couldn't tell in your book whether
Occupy Wall Street inspires you or
scares you
actually I think Occupy Wall Street is
is part of a bigger movement it's really
a continuation of Arab Spring and it's
it was found in Madrid before Occupy
Wall Street and it's after that it's
found in Russia with street
demonstrations it's a democratic
movement and it's a discovery that
people are rediscovering that protests
can bring down governments and can make
big changes so I'm inspired by that part
of it that I think that they're they're
bringing up the dissatisfaction with the
inequality that's developing in our
society people have been saying people
don't really care well now we know that
they do care and that they're wanting to
make a change but I guess might disquiet
with 99 percent is that they're they
some of them seem to be saying that my
students are doing the wrong thing I
think that my students I don't speak for
all of them they're all over the world i
guess but i think that there's a they
are doing something just as important if
they go into finance and fix it from the
inside and so that's where I differ from
so Occupy Wall Street came by Yale
recruiters for finance companies and
protested as if they were Nazis or
something that's that's where it's wrong
well I mean this is this is old saying
that the problem with socialism is
socialism the problem of capitalism is
capitalists all right but there's this
notion in that that I wonder your book
lays out these sort of idealistic roles
for everyone in the system of finance
from board members to CEOs to bankers
but you mention it but it seems that the
market creates a great place where more
base virtues like greed and competition
can create a better outcome see this is
the thing where this is where we need
behavioral finance people say why our
CEOs compensated so much because
you know in in the past they would do
these things out of the goodness of
their heart I mean to some extent that's
true you know you feel this
responsibility for the employees Louis
you to tell had a book in which he
writes about executives over the last 50
years and argues that they used to feel
more heartfelt concern for their
employees and there's been some decline
in that so I think that we are culture
maybe could emphasize carrying more I
mean I think maybe we're heading that
way but the other side of it is does
that mean that we don't company could we
make a law against paying 50 million
dollars to a CEO and I'm thinking well
50 million is pretty high it's been done
depends on your perspective but that's
the point I think that maybe we
shouldn't outlaw that and because you
see the thing is because people are
complicated you know Lee Iacocca agreed
to work for one dollar when he was
taking over at Chrysler when it was
failing so is that what that he offered
to do that that's great but can we just
count on that I don't think so there's a
mixture of and people have motives for
anything they do like that it is the
heart of sometimes the heart of a deal
right whether it's on Wall Street or its
boards by a car the buyer hopes the
seller is going to overpay right you get
into a cell seller thinks wants just the
opposite outcome were they they the two
forces that want to take advantage of
each other will in the in the aggregate
arrive at a better pricing those aren't
those aren't virtue istic goals and a
transaction but it works see there are
certain career I like my career as a
college professor I don't I don't get
into very many moral dilemmas like that
I used car salesman would be a difficult
career for me because because it doesn't
do fine
so that's life I mean different careers
push you in different direction so i
think the career of a CEO is
fundamentally important because they
guide an organization and the reason
they're paid well there's two reasons
why they're paid from so much a good
reason and a bad reason the good reason
is take some guy who's been running
companies he's 60 years old he's been
great you know he has great people
skills and he knows how to turn a
company around supposedly maybe maybe he
does and now another company is failing
they've got 10,000 employees they were a
great company and they're failing and
someone says bring him in maybe he can
fix it you know he's done thing they
want him but then he says look I'm tired
you know my wife wants me to retire you
know 10 million dollars just doesn't
interest him so they bid him up and they
say well give you 50 million dollars so
he goes back to his wife and she says
week I could get 50 million dollars if I
did this and then let's start a family
foundation maybe and we can be tellers
of the community where we're 10 million
wouldn't got that done if it 10 million
will only value one house in San
Francisco so so and so but you also
didn't let me get the big obvious the
bad reason is he's got cronies on the
board and they they say it will pretend
to fool the shareholders will say that
you're a great executive and remember me
sometimes you know I gave you a favor it
can't be explicit but someday you'll pay
me back that happens to that's crony
capitalism so it's not perfect so we
sarbanes-oxley tried to regulate that by
putting outside requiring that outside
members on the compensation committees I
don't know if that fixed it but so there
are issues about executive compensation
and that's what comes to my mind when
you talk about in the book about the
method and this gives just well first
the questions I want to get to which is
about
you in the book talk about preferring
stock options but not bonus and not cash
bonuses as a method to make CEOs better
motivated aligned with interest the
company but stock options have been a
heart of scandals at Global Crossing
tenet healthcare quest homestore calm
you name it and yet you think stock
options is a better way to go than
bonuses well there's an argument
everything is complicated there's an
argument for stock options because if
you give a CEO a bonus for making a lot
of profits this year the CEO has an
incentive to just milk the company for
profits the typical CEO is only going to
be there for a few years so you don't do
any long-term planning you you destroy
your customer base you sell things off
and play tricks to make profits that
doesn't work as well if your
compensation is based on the stock price
because then the the the the investors
see that and see through it and the
price falls that's the idea but again
it's still imperfect because the CEO can
still play tricks by concealing bad news
and creating false impression of good
news that pushes the stock price up so I
don't know the perfect system that's why
we keep have to keep have to keep
experimenting and moving forward and we
also have to think about motivating
well-meaning people who don't play
tricks like that as much so that's why I
think the benefit corporation might help
solve that kind of problem well you
recruit somebody to do a social purpose
I think it changes the whole atmosphere
so it's not something sarbanes-oxley was
not as imaginative as we could be in
fixing that problem and I think there
will be other ideas and solutions that
come forward later question you from the
audience about social investing what
role should environmental social and
corporate governance analysis planned
finance in vanden picking and
sustainable investment portfolios
corporate governments governance
analysis you mean studying
how boards work oh and environmental
social impacts of the companies what
they're doing this old notion of social
investing yes it's an old notion so it's
not I think that we haven't focused on
that enough I think maybe this is a
trend that will come back we were going
through we went through a period in our
history particularly in the United
States where the greed is good mentality
predominated and it was associated with
the efficient markets hypothesis it was
in reaction to abuses that people who
claim to be serving the public good
actually filtered money to themselves
there's a famous quote from Adam Smith's
Wealth of Nations written in 1776 I
can't quote it from memory but something
to the effect that the the baker the the
butcher the people that serve our lives
are not doing it out of the kindness of
their hearts they were doing it for a
profit motive and I'm trying to quote
him approximately I he said I think that
it's those people who serve us better
than the self-described philanthropist
in some sense he's true because there
isn't that much philanthropy most of
what we get is involved with other
people giving and so I think we
overemphasize the Adam Smith view or
that view of Adam Smith he wasn't so
simple he was complicated too and we
lived in a period where we thought that
we were evangelizing to the world the
virtues of of self-interested
profit-making and I know that that was a
mood on our campuses and in our business
offices that we tightened up the the and
I mentioning lucha tells book that came
out a few years ago he interviewed
executive and he could see the change
that executives 20-30 years ago felt
more of a mission for their employees
than they do now and so it's a change in
our thinking and I bet the pendulum is
swinging back we were in an extreme
period
of selfish capitalism and we we are
moving out of it well let me slow move
the question on everyone's favorite a
way to give back to the community taxes
at what level would you advocate a
corporate tax rate and why okay well so
this is actually tak somebody loves
because it's somebody else playing in
corporate tax rate okay there are lots
of economists who say it should be zero
because it's double taxation
corporations are owned by people some of
them in low tax brackets some of them in
high tax brackets for example the
firemen's pension fund will have money
in in the stock market so what what do
we want to do about corporate taxation I
think that it's there's a plausible
argument for setting it to 0 but there
are other arguments as well that
suggests that maybe it shouldn't be 0
you understand that any organization can
get out of the corporate profits tax by
redefining themselves as a partnership
rather than a corporation and a lot of
groups do that they tend to be small
groups of lawyers or accountants are
typically partnerships rather than
corporations so you can do that but
there but they suffer liability that
they can be sued and it can take your
home or your car so some other
organizations tend to choose corporate
store it tends to encourage big
organizations but they also impose costs
on society because if they do something
wrong they they can't be sued for it so
for example TEPCO in Japan ran the
fukushima nuclear power plant it caused
this huge disaster and now you can't go
after the shareholders the shareholders
were profiting from a nuclear power
plant that wasn't done right and then
after it's over they say sorry you know
we're not you can't take it from us so
the Japanese taxpayer has to pay for it
so that's why there is an argument for
right for having a tax on corporate
profits but is it should the tanks be
set on the almost theoretical liability
or the cost of having a corporation or
having all corporations or should it be
said on some level of need in the
community oh I thought you were asking a
very technical question and say you said
need in the community I don't remember
they have me a lot of weight little haha
I've heard discussions in public finance
about optimal corporate taxation now
remember this need in the community but
on some level that's what the
discussions about right when it was
angry about the level of corporate
taxation it's about why should we as
individuals be taxed so high when the
rich corporations are being taxed so low
whether wonder if you have any notion of
where should be said well I'm going to
be an academic and say that's a very
complicated funds all right listen let's
let us move out more great questions
from the from the audience oh the jobs
legislation which you mention in his
current form do you think it'll be
beneficial and I on a reference Jesse
Eisinger what a great column in The New
York Times recently referring to it as
the bucket shop Employment Act of 2012
that taking away regulations protecting
investors maybe isn't after enron and
worldcom and so on might not be the best
thing in the crowdfunding as a cute name
bucket shop is well you know that yeah
bucket shop is the name for a
institution that was common in the late
19th century and then faded it
disappeared I think it became outlawed a
bucket shop was the place where you
would go and have a glass of whiskey and
there'd be a painting of a nude girl up
there and you would bet on stock prices
and they got people they got men and
you'd smoke a big cigar and you'd go in
there and at the end of the day you lost
everything so we don't want that you
know what I may have Kobe might've also
refer to as a boiler-room Employment Act
well boiler room is a little different
the was that what they say well yeah one
of the reasons another sabor larue what
came in when they invented telephones
and they became common so people ready
have it but when they got long-distance
phone calling
in the 1920s that came into a boiler
room you were in the cheapest real
estate you can and that would be the
basement of some building with a boiler
is all right and you'd hire phone people
to make phone calls to investors and
they would pretend they're calling from
some glamorous Wall Street office and
they call all around the country and
they say i have this hot new stock for
you that's going to take off but i'm
going to let you in on the secret that's
a boiler room and yes those were abuses
they were they were they both the bucket
shops and the boiler rooms were abusing
less informed people who didn't
understand and so they were both
regulated out and we and we have to be
aware of that that's why it's a
controversial idea the crowdfunding is a
controversial idea because it could
bring that back so that's in the act the
ACT has restrictions on it it can't be
like I mentioned a man would go in with
the family fortune to the bucket shop
and at the end of the day he had lost
the whole thing it can't happen because
it's no more than two percent of your
income and so that is a fundamental
protection so let's not think in
oversimplified terms bucket shops and
boiler rooms were serious problems in an
earlier day but let's not be too afraid
of American free enterprise involving
the people because I think that it might
this experiment might really work and it
might be an inspiration that would see
how it goes and we can change it if it
doesn't work I guess there's a notion in
this of two of stomaching some fraud i
mean my in my prior life prior to
hosting bloomberg west it was finding
fakes and frauds and phony companies and
there are those characters out there who
will always use these to create phony
stock promotions run these things up
without any result let me say something
about self-regulation we have this
organization called finra which is a
trade organization of stockbrokers and
the like which imposes ethical standards
from within the industry and they will
do continuing education that reaffirms
the
ethical standards and what they actually
do for stock brokers in this country
they have them watched little movie
clips and the movie clip will show of
stockbrokers sitting in his office and
then a client comes in and and says
let's do something a little shady you
know this thing has I'm going to sign
this it's supposed to be my husband's
signature but I'll sign it and we'll
just not tell anybody and then in the
movie he acquiesces and then he's ruined
they show hit what happens all of the
consequences so they are trying to
remind people that it's a slippery slope
all those will inspire people well no
it's not well there they do show in
these movies other people who have that
the safest route to avoiding getting on
the slippery slope where now you've done
something wrong and now you have to
cover it up and then it gets worse and
worse this is to be squeaky clean all
the time and that's the inspiration you
do it out of moral conviction so you
tell her I will not accept your fake
signature because I just can't imagine
myself ever doing such a thing I'm
inspired already a number of people sent
questions here about glass-steagall do
you think last Eagle should be
reinstated and is that a big issue that
needs to be dealt with okay the
glass-steagall act in 34 i think it was
it was an act that created Federal
Deposit Insurance Corporation and it
also told banks that they couldn't get
involved in what's called investment
banking which is the more risky side of
banking and the reason they put the two
together in the same bill is that they
thought well if the government is going
to ensure banks we have to make sure
they don't do risky things and that was
the idea of glass-steagall it went along
until the late 20th century and then it
was repealed then more recently Paul
Volcker got another version called the
Volcker Rule which was brought into the
dodd-frank act for much the same reason
it was a little different these banks
were bailed out by the government and it
cost the taxpayers money so well it's
basically the same reason so but he
wanted to define the rule a little
differently than glass-steagall but it's
the same idea that banks can't do
proprietary trading risky trading on
their own account and so I think that
was it then you get bogged down in the
details though and this is where the
lobbyists come in now I don't think
they're uniformly evil maybe some of
them are evil I have a chapter in my
book on lobbyists and I think most
people are mixture of good and evil and
the lobbyists I think are skilled in
finance and they point out you're going
to shut down all these activities in our
bank but they're integral to what we do
when we provide services to the
customers and you can't just shut this
down well you can but you'll destroy our
banking system and we won't be
competitive with the international
situation and can you just tinker with
this rule a little bit so that we can do
this that we've always been doing and so
it gets more and more complicated now is
that evil is the Volcker Rule still
functioning well that's a deep big and
deep question my thought is usually in
like they are not a good debater because
I think that usually in life it's
somewhere in the middle right I could
debate either side of some important
point but then I would be disallowed V
feeling dishonest same thing with
efficient markets it's a half-truth it's
not completely wrong it's not completely
right either so I think the Volcker rule
is an extraordinarily difficult thing to
discuss in a in a venue like this but I
think that it's not wrong for the
government to get involved with that
kind of rulemaking the details are
monstrous so a lot of questions about
investing and where your investments are
and so on but I but an intriguing one
here how does investing the stock market
contribute to the real economy outside
of the obvious investing in IPO as a
secondary market sort of creating a
market for a new company
okay so this gets back to Karl Marx who
said it was gambling more recently a lot
of people said that stock market doesn't
fulfill any social function because
companies don't raise that much capital
by issuing stock anyway and so what's
all this activity for there's been the
debate about this in the academic
finance literature well it turns out
that companies do issue stock to finance
them their business but it's often in
the form of options to employees or
executives still it's still issuing
issuing stock so I don't think that it's
a bad thing that I the notion that it
contributes the economy beyond sort of
employment and things you did well does
the existence of a Markham you're
talking about futures trading in a in an
index creating the opportunity to risk
yeah there's this sense that there's all
this trading back and forth and it's
wasted activity well I the question is
what do we what do we do about them it
looks wasteful a lot of things look you
know I'll give you a peril I mentioned
this in my book look at all the all the
cashiers at stores right if everyone
we're completely honest we could just
say put your money in you don't need
anyone watching you that it seems like
there's a tremendous waste in Sam bowls
who's a right a left wing economist did
an estimate of the amount of guards will
you talk with an it was a huge forget
the exact number was a huge percent of
the lots of things happen that seemed
wasteful I think I dls think that were
chamber son of the US economy people
guarding something yes right and that
seems wasteful but then the question is
everything is imperfect and this system
that we have we don't really understand
why it works as well as it does given
the imperfections of people and and so
you look at certain things that seem
wrong that seem wasteful but
they're kind of consequences of a of a
of a system that has other purposes so I
there is this thing about the Tobin tag
my colleague at Yale proposed that we
put a tax on transactions to discourage
all this trading back and forth and
there's a big push about this particular
high-frequency trading and high
frequency or millisecond trading now you
have traders that will program a
computer to trade within a thousandth of
a second they they can respond faster
than anybody else to market situation
and what they sometimes do is a place a
buy order for one millisecond okay it
goes out bang everything is electronic
now one millisecond is that the only odd
now the question is that bad now I don't
necessarily know the answer to
everything you're asking me so I'll try
to give my answer open someone knows I
think that it's it's harm it's
relatively harmless and I've talked to
people who do millisecond trading and
they say I don't see what the big issue
is i'm doing the same basic business
that I used to do it's just like an
engineer who used to have a slide rule
to do calculations and now he has a
computer and he does millisecond micro
second calculations everything is sped
up and we kind of have to live with the
world is faster and if you don't get in
line first that means in the first
millisecond your customer might lose out
but so we always get in line first but
is it essential and the the idea is no
we're doing the same business we've
always done and if you look at the
forbes 400 list of richest people i
don't think any one of them is a
millisecond trader so i don't think that
it's as dangerous as it may seem and
what we've milled it's like a
billionaires though it could happen
anything can change you know I don't
know what risks the millisecond trading
might someday have it I don't see it as
a central issue now do you see a role
expanded role for the government to sort
of pick favored borrowers because of the
social good so that you have borrowers
who are you know obviously the
government has given breaks to
homeowners right tax breaks so that
they'd be cut to inspire people to buy
more hair but should that go beyond
there are benefits municipal lending
right to building bridges and tunnels
and roads and so on but do you as part
of your notion in the book that the
government could get involved to inspire
these benefit corporations or Public
Works and lending for drug treatment
clinics or churches or or community
centers or whatever well I think what
you're describing was called by henry
clay the american system do you know
that Henry Clay was a great u.s. senator
and he coined the term the American
system so what do you imagine that is
well partly it's something that I don't
particularly like high tariffs but
forget that part of the American system
the other part of the American system
was government involvement in promoting
enterprise the government's got involved
in building canals in improving harbors
they were this country was not less a
fair I mean it had a lesson he's fair
element to it but it it did it was the
really less a faire economics came later
notably in the mid-to-late 20th century
so I don't think that there's and I
think that it does pay to have a
government that thinks of so governor
Clinton in New York advocated for years
supporting the Erie Canal and and it was
a private investment but it had the
support of the government a wonderful
thing that happened the government and
then with the railroads the government
supported the railroads I don't think
that we want to leave things entirely to
let a fair market forces so we went to
we have to be careful too because you
can go too far in this again this is my
my philosophy as a teacher most things
are half-truths and we don't have clear
and solid laws in economics that
approach those of physics there's going
to be some role for the government but
then once the government has a
all there's a there's a risk that
they'll be bribed or bought out and go
too far well it's a complicated world
but i actually have faith that this
country is moving for and so is the
whole world moving forward it's less
corrupt than it used to be we have a lot
of laws and regulations that are making
it harder to do these evil things and it
looks complicated and it's annoying but
its civilization well let me ask we just
got time for just one quick question
here less than two minutes left here but
you write in the book that finance is
not about making money right so in a
minute what is it alright well I have my
own etymology of the word you know I
shouldn't have my own Adam it you may I
it's sort of an expansive edameh look
out finance in the dictionary and it
says it comes from old french but before
that it comes from the latin word
thinnest fi n is which means end and why
did the dictionary different
dictionaries say different things but
the basic idea is that it comes somehow
from when you completed a financial deal
they would write thinnest at the end in
Latin meaning deal done and so somehow
that became finance but I was noting
that the word finis in ancient Latin
classical latin means end and i was
wondering in english the word and has
two meanings it means the final step but
it also means purpose right what are
your ends what are your goals and i
found in an old latin classical latin
dictionary that it had exactly that
double meaning in ancient times so finis
meant goal purpose and so i think that
what i'm thinking is that finance my
definition of finance is it's about
financing activities making things
happen that means allowing people to
achieve their goals if you democratize
finance different people have different
goals some of them are religious groups
some of them are hospitals some you know
some people want to see
scientific progress different people
have different goals we want to make it
possible to achieve those goals so
another example I mentioned in my book
you have a child with handicapped and
the child is going to live longer than
you you want to protect this child now
what are you going to do the child is
unable of taking care of himself or
herself so you want to create a trust
for the child you can go to a trust
company and say I want you to manage
this account for my child after I'm gone
and they do that that's part of modern
finance that's just one example of the
kind of goals that people have the
problem is that most of our important
goals in life take that form I can't do
it myself I need other people to support
this goal and I want to continue through
time it's not a goal for the next year I
to go for a hundred years or whatever
and and so that's how I define so
finance is about stewardship protection
of goals and it's about getting people
to work together effectively to
achievement of goals now that is not a
definition of Finance you'll find in any
textbook it's my exam definitely you're
terrific book and I told you the book
was inspiring see we're out of time
thanks Robert Shiller economist and
best-selling author of finance and
a good society thanks to our audience
here and on the radio and television and
the Internet I'm Corey Johnson now this
meeting of the Commonwealth Club of
California the place where you're in the
know is adjourned very much wonderful
job you signed books right here right
here you did a great job we'd like to
hear from you tweet us your feedback